I can't wait until my car gets fixed!
Didn't you say it's convenient to take the subway to work?
With all due respect, Oyon, I beg to differ.
First of all, it takes 2 hours for me to get to work!
That's 4 hours of my precious time going down the drain, every morning and evening.
Second of all, there are so many people on the subway!
Why is it always so crowded?
No privacy at all, either.
People talk so loud on their cell phones, it's incredible.
I respect what you said, but I still think you're better off on the subway than behind the wheel.
First of all, you can use those 4 hours of time to do something useful.
You can read books or the newspaper,...
...or you can even take a nap if you have a seat.
But there's no way you can do those things while driving.
Second of all, taking the subway does not cost as much money as driving a car.
You have to pay for gas and maintenance if you have a car,...
...but that's not the case with public transportation.
Speaking of public transportation, the subway is not the only means.
There are buses, too!
Let's see if there's a bus that runs between here and where you live.